Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and this week
Rebels paired up Ezra and Zeb for a very special
Tie Fighter Field Trip.
Normally I just point out my favorite references
and do a review but I spotted some funny subliminal
messages that I’ll explain too.
If you’re just finding me I’m doing weekly
Rebels videos.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
Careful for spoilers if you haven’t seen
the episode but here are my TOP 5 moments.
Number 5 - Chopper Robo Trolls Everyone
The R5 Droid being an asshole provides the
call to action that sets the big Ezra Zeb
field trip in motion.
But it didn’t stop there.
Later in the episode when Kanan and Hera were
chilling out playing Dejarik, Chopper really
let them have it.
The scene was a nice reference to the R2 versus
Chewbacca match in Episode 4 with the twist
that Chopper didn’t have to let Kanan win
for fear of getting his arms ripped out of
their sockets.
When Ezra and Zeb came back he doubled down
on harassing them.
I’m surprised Zeb didn’t prank him with
a restraining bolt or something.
Troll me once, shame on you, troll me twice,
shame on me.
Number 4 - The Wookiee Life Debt
They don’t specify how much time has passed
since the last episode, but Ezra is still
having fun with Zeb for saving his life.
The Wookiee life debt isn’t explained in
the original trilogy really well but the expanded
universe and the comics picked up the slack.
Chewbacca was rescued from an Imperial Prison
Ship by a young Han Solo.
He had been ordered to kill him by his Imperial
supervisor but instead freed Chewie and the
other Wookiees, al lot like the crew of the
Ghost did in the first episode.
When a Wookiee owes their life to someone,
the debt lasts until they are dead.
But I think their children can also choose
to honor it under special circumstances.
It’s nice to see them coming together as
a group but Zeb seemed a little too easy to
bait.
He’s not a version of Chewbacca or anything,
but he does fill that role in the crew.
The big scary alien covered in fur.
Yes this is a kid’s show, but I feel like
he would be more fun if they just let him
be scary and over the course of the series
Ezra won him over.
It seems like he wears his emotions on his
sleeves, or wrist bands or whatever he’s
wearing there.
Under normal circumstances, after Ezra and
Chopper busted in on him sleeping, I would
expect someone with his personality to just
shoot a warning shot at them with a small
blaster.
Just to scare them off.
We learned last week his entire race was slaughtered
with a few exceptions, so I’m not sensing
the typical Post Traumatic Stress Behavior
you’d expect.
Number 3 - All For Love of Fruit
They were there for regular supplies, which
they lost.
But Hera trolls them a little with a mission
to nowhere, so she thinks.
She wasn’t trying to be mean, but it is
funny to think that everything in the episode
that happened was a result of them being kind
of rotten to each other.
Even Sabine made fun of them with the graffiti
in their room.
It wasn’t her trying to be awful to them.
But in a really subtle way I felt like the
show was telling us all these characters have
good hearts, but they’re still really selfish.
And if you didn’t catch it in the Dejarik
scene.
Hera and Kanan are totally doing it on the
down low.
They haven’t had a lot of scenes together
in the last 3 episodes.
But there are some trailer clips with them
‘almost kissing’ so you can tell they
have a relationship that the show will explore
at some point.
Hera is one of the few characters we haven’t
spent a lot of time with yet but she and Sabine
will both get their own episodes soon.
Number 2 - Ezra Learns to Use the Force
It takes him most of the episode to land the
trick but he’s able to use some limited
force telekinesis.
As of now he’s exhibited near future premonitions,
a force push and now telekenisis.
I guess you could say he’s made some small
force jumps.
Some of his rooftop acrobatics are a little
superhuman.
We still haven’t seen him train with Kanan’s
lightsaber, I think that will be next.
That and just getting better at the lesser
Jedi powers.
They gave Zeb the Obi-Wan Kenobi line, “This
is not the tie fighter you’re looking for”.
But after some lightsaber training I think
we’ll see Ezra start to learn how to influence
weaker minds.
The stormtroopers on the show are pretty dumb,
so they’ll be easy targets.
Of all the Jedi Powers, the ones that allow
you to control others are harder to master.
So I’m interested to see if they just let
him do it right away or if he has to work
up to it.
If they’re planning on doing a big Ezra
force weilding moment in the finale this year
it would probably be a lightsaber battle with
the inquisitor.
Like the first time luke fought Vader and
got his ass “handed” to him.
Ezra is learning to use the force, but he
is light years away from being able to take
on someone as skilled as the Inquisitor.
I would be pissed if they let him win a lightsaber
battle with him.
Even Anakin Skywalker wasn’t that great
with a lightsaber when he first started.
In order for villains to be a threat, they
have to seem unbeatable.
And my Number 1 moment - Tie Fighter Joyrides
Totally loved them stealing a Tie Fighter,
did not love all the flying through the city.
I get that Zeb hadn’t flown one before but
I feel like they let the moment drag on too
long.
Him talking to Ezra, flying it along side
him while Ezra ran on the roof tops.
It felt a little more like a Family Guy gag,
like Peter is flying a Tie Fighter up and
down the aisles of a grocery store.
Casual Use of Tie Fighters is a funny concept
but I feel like the joke peaked when he was
spinning it in circles blasting everyone.
I think they could have cut away sooner and
used the extra time for a scene where the
imperials punish the farmers for everything.
They didn’t really follow the rescue idea
through to the logical conclusion.
Ezra and Zeb crash the tie fighter so the
imperials don’t find them, but then after
they leave the planet, the imperials just
go back and kill the farmer and his wife.
They were very clearly trying to do the Uncle
Owen Aunt Beru episode 4 scene with the smoldering
ruins.
It’s a kid’s show like I said, so they’re
not going to murder a bunch of people.
But don’t you feel like the imperials would
go right back after Ezra and Zeb flew off.
He didn’t destroy their transports.
Just one of the gun turrets.
They had more weapons.
And they’re not the only imperials on the
planet.
Part of the theme this week was taking the
quick and easy way will leave you worse off
than when you started.
They had the supplies but because Ezra wanted
to steal the fruit they lost everything.
And even though they saved his farmer friend.
The Empire is still going to take their farm.
So they didn’t change anything.
Let me know what your favorite moment was
and let me know if you spotted these subliminal
messages:
I feel like this is a little Disney Propaganda
here but first and most obvious was that you
should eat more fruit.
Ezra almost got them killed because he loves
fruit so much.
The storm trooper even asked him, “you did
this all for fruit?”
The other big one was when Zeb gave him the
Tie Fighter Helmet.
I feel like that’s Disney telling you to
buy more Star Wars toys.
Ezra collects toys, toys cost money, a lot
of money.
Money equals profit.
Anytime I see characters lusting after objects
like they’re toys I feel like it’s merchandising
for Star Wars toys in real life.
George Lucas made millions of dollars on the
movies, but he made Billions of Dollars on
the toys.
The toys are where all the money is.
Overall I gave the episode a B minus, I feel
like there was a good moral throughline about
not straying from the path too far and working
together as a team.
I feel like they’re doing Zeb’s character
a disservice in making him so quick to open
up to a kid.
Ezra that is.
He’s younger than Luke was when he boarded
the Millenium Falcon.
Young children who mostly hang around adults
in cartoons tend to fall into a couple categories.
They’re either a Bart Simpson character
who gets into mischief all the time, like
Aladdin.
I know everyone is calling Ezra Space Aladdin.
Or they’re Meg Griffin and they become the
but of all the jokes.
I don’t think that Ezra is Meg, I do like
the direction they’re taking his character.
But I don’t like it as much when they really
lean hard on the Bart Simpson stuff.
Stealing the heads off of Stormtroopers and
pranking Zeb.
Who I guess in this analogy would be Moe the
Bartender.
I’m really excited to see more of the inquisitor,
who I think is coming back in episode 4 next
week.
Since Monday nights I’m usually working
on Gotham, I’ll just be posting Rebels videos
on Tuesdays, so be sure to subscribe to get
everything.
There’s a lot going on this week with the
new Legend of Korra game, I’ll be streaming
that.
So check the description for those links.
Right now click here for Rebels Episode 2
and click here to catch up on Legend of Korra.
Thanks for watching, now let’s all high
five and stream some Korra.